foreign
[Music]
ER oh no it's going
all right just a bit of hanging so
someone complained to us about doing too
many Patron episodes you know what they
eat you know what the easy four dollar
solution to that is I know I know we can
tell we can tell yeah it's start a start
a revolution we never have to pay for
anything again plus we we know how much
you make and you know who you are
oh my God always
uh that's two that's that's inside
baseball Let's uh let's talk about Pablo
Neruda he was poisoned was he poisoned
he didn't die after the penis Shay
regime moved in he was poisons now
was he where did when did that come out
I read it on democracy now it looks like
it has been picked up by a few Outlets
the guardian says forensic science study
finds Chilean poet Pablo nerudo was
poisoned that was three days ago very
recent even USA Today saying Pablo
Neruda was due to poison not cancer they
said it was cancer before
really oh wow I didn't know that I
actually don't didn't know the story of
um
why of like how he originally did like
what the original story of how he died
was
yeah so it's interesting it says
according to the official version this
is on the guardian uh naruta uh who made
his name as a young poet with uh those
20 poems of love and a song a despair
died from prostate cancer and
malnutrition on September 23rd 1973 12
days after the coup that ousted Salvador
Allende the democratically elected
president
um some including his nephew long
believed he was murdered and blah blah
blah now it seems there is evidence that
he was murdered or at least there is
Foul Play of some kind involved unless
he poisoned himself accidentally or
something but um
that seems unlikely we should be digging
up a whole bunch of
intellectuals but I mean there's lots of
bodies to dig up but specifically
intellectuals who killed themselves
suspiciously
including at this end because of our
previous track record of talking about
Chile and it's the uh Coupe can I say
one more thing about this this new thing
I see the CBC version of the article
that talks about this they always like
to shout out when it's like involves a
Canadian and apparently one of the
scientists who discovered this is from
McMaster University in Hamilton Ontario
yeah we have a massive inferiority
complex
yeah like the CBC will always just any
story that's happening on the world
stage if you read the CBC version if a
Canadian is involved they will make sure
that you know about it no no we we do
that too though anytime it is a Canadian
that's mentioned we we mentioned that
it's a Canadian specifically who's being
mentioned yeah I remember actually one
time I I when I first discovered This
American Life obviously which was kind
of like one of the first successful
narrative podcasts
I remember going into their back catalog
and they had an old episode about Canada
and they interviewed
uh one dude and he was just talking
about how all Canadians in the states
have like an uncanny ability to just
tell their American friends whenever a
person comes up they're like oh he's
Canadian he's Canadian this is an INF an
inferiority jingoism
exactly it's like John John Candy comes
up oh it's Canadian
Alex Trebek Canadian oh Judo yeah
speaking of assassinations
as far as I know and this is one of the
things I like about the podcast again is
I don't have to cite my sources but I'm
pretty sure I'm pretty sure cast and
undergraduate degrees that gee de Boer
shot himself in the heart and I gotta
say who the [__] does that you know
but that's okay he gives us some
suspicion maybe it was symbolic for him
that would be he seems like an over
dramatic and really self-involved dude I
was just gonna say that that sounds like
that's that I'm actually not surprised
that that's how he killed himself but in
the beginning of this book shot through
the house number one he he just or
exposes his conspiratorial mindset by
saying that I obviously cannot speak
with complete freedom because having
then to account for the readers who are
both attentive and diversely influential
I obviously cannot speak with complete
Freedom above all I must take care not
to give too much information to just
anyone our unfortunate times this compel
me once again to write in a new way some
elements will be intentionally omitted
and the plan will have to remain rather
unclear readers will encounter certain
decoys like the very Hallmark of the era
so we are reading folks comments on the
Society of spectacle written I think
exactly 20 years after the society
spectacle 1987.
the tldr of the book is by the way I was
not wrong about everything I was in fact
right about everything but what do you
guys think of this very self this is
very self-involved introduction where
he's he thinks like the CIA need to read
his book
to get tips on the spectacle because of
how influential the book is and also
he's trying to signal to the reader by
the way there's going to be a lot of
you're going to have to decode this this
is a kabbalah-esque
peak of fear theoretical writing and
people are people are on to it and that
CIA report that you looked at did
Deborah come up at all by the way did
Deborah come I don't know you know what
he was influential in the sense that
like during May 1968 for example many of
his slogans or the slogans from the
situationists became like
um like they'd be spray painted onto
walls for example one of them is
um
or something like that which means it's
forbidden to forbid
oh yeah yeah that's uh who that that
opens up a whole can of worms uh but I
was gonna
but no the CIA report I will say the CRA
report did not mention him at all which
I'm sure after having read this these
comments this comment book he would be
probably upset no he'd be oh he'll be
upset okay because I was gonna say for
the audience that doesn't know what
we're talking about one of pills this
video is actually one of my favorite of
his videos uh looks at radical theory on
the CIA and a report that I think they
basically investigated into the threat
assessment they're like how much of a
threat is French Theory and they
basically concluded that it wasn't a
threat and it was all infighting and it
was all like this is no threat to us
this is consist this is consistent with
our interests basically so I would have
thought that Deborah would have been
happy to not be included because
maybe he they did they were separately
talking about Deborah as maybe an actual
threat whereas these uh like Circle
jerkers weren't were they were were they
in those in those CIA things though were
they generally looking at the 50s the
1950s intellectuals
no they were looking at the 80s I think
the 50s they were much more of a threat
because they were like part of the
mobilization but in the 80s they were
like okay these these kids or they were
kids you know Foucault and uh dillas and
Etc they were all kids in the 60s and
now they're like growing up and
Publishing and becoming really famous
like becoming yeah
relatively so they're like is this a
threat for like another 68 and the
answer was nah
especially and uh specifically in
comparison to more doctrina Marxism
right that like focuses on materialism
and focuses on like mobilizing class
struggle and then it's like you get to
these more like post-structuralists
post-modern French theorists and they're
just like yeah this isn't a threat at
all this is no problem for us
or or the badooian kids who are like
smashing up their classroom trying to
look for CIA microphones in their
classroom there's this huge like
self-inflated sense of the importance of
what they're doing and I'm gonna pass
that on to Deborah as well hugely
inflated sense of importance about what
a little pamphlet is gonna do to change
the world I I would
be cautious about attributing it to
anything about these intellectuals
though like I wouldn't say there's
something wrong with postmodern Theory
which the CIA has successfully assessed
I would say that
it's part of the times there's a
historical reason right after the 60s
during the 60s spectacle Rises to its
prominence okay 70s neoliberalism sets
in by the 80s you don't have you know
the close relationship of intellectuals
with governments you don't have that
kind of celebrity that used to have back
in the Jean-Paul Sartre days so I think
there's a good historical explanation it
doesn't say as much about post-modern
Theory as such as it does about The
Changing Times that's true I mean I
don't think that it says anything about
whether postmodern theory is good or
convincing or not it's more like a
threat assessment right it's like is it
a threat to American interests yeah
right so like but about whether it's a
threat or not I mean maybe that could be
the litmus test for some radicals I
guess and that's kind of why it's a bit
of a dunk on some radicals because for
them maybe a litmus test would be like
it should be a threat right
it's just not but the fact that it's not
it doesn't necessarily say anything
about the quality of the philosophical
work that's being done right it just
says more about its practice the
potential for its practical impact in
the real world which I think the CAA are
pretty correct to say uh pretty Limited
yeah this is a this is a good thing to
hit home because they did consider the
French Communist party it was like the
second largest party after the war
um and then they say you know the Le the
neolib left is in power in France and we
don't have to worry about the country
anymore
let's wrap up and go home boys yeah yeah
after they killed the board of course
yeah if if they did and three to lose
out of an apartment building yeah after
supposedly burning all of the rest of
his work I don't think so we need to we
need to get toxicology on guitari also
sudden heart attack those things don't
just happen if they uh if they did say
it was a threat I would have then had to
ask well why what are they looking at
but saying it's not a threat means it's
like either they missed something or
good they're not worried good for them
they can pay attention to cracking
regimes and whatever else they like like
the the like the kind of intellectual
left is feels pretty neutered when it
comes to like like direct action
well yeah the the the left the left the
late left
and the the only direct action that they
tend to be involved in lately has to do
with more identity issues which also
really isn't a threat to Capital which
also isn't a threat to neoliberalism
yeah it's it's again it's that spectacle
self-criticism it's it's contained it's
it's it's innocuous it's
it's these new conditions
the spectacle is kind of new in a way he
said it was about 40 years old when he
was writing in the 60s so it's it's and
then he he adds something which we'll
get to in this in these comments but
I think the spectacle is a good
explainer of why the left has failed
because they've become spectacular
having this is spectacleized yeah the
spectacle is a tumor on something that's
real and the real stuff is still there
it's just like it's more easy to engage
with the spectacle it's more easy to
fight people there it's more easy to
write pamphlets I don't know why he
doesn't think his book is part of the
spectacle
that might be something worth saying but
instead I wanted to focus I think he
showed here a level of assholery that
I've been hesitant to bring up because I
wanted to give it the most charitable
reading the first bit that we read him
because we've been doing the
situationist now for over a month but he
seems like an [__]
from like not only getting into fights
banishing people from his group all the
time writing these tracks about he I
think he wrote something about sart that
said you know starts a corpse when he
wasn't yet a corpse course
um but he all this infighting and then
here this intro I that I'm still not
over I must take care not to give too
much information to just anybody and
maybe I'm being
triggered by relationships with people
that I've met like this because you guys
are you guys are gonna know the types
that I'm talking about the academic
especially a grad student that they
don't have nothing to show for [__] but
because they think they're so smart and
since their narcissism has triumphed in
their own in their own mind they are
this huge deal if not now then soon and
that's the difference because the board
actually wrote a book but you know the
grad student who's worried about
everyone stealing their ideas
because they are about to change the
landscape of Academia and Theory forever
or or in the board's case
that shadowy forces are combing his book
so he has to throw them off by putting
secrets in it so that sounds like what
he's doing here yes he wrote a very
famous book yeah he's quoted and cited
often for this concept but he's implying
that like I don't know uh McKinsey is
going to be reading his book looking for
looking for proclamations about the
future and this this is better for him I
guess to believe than the truth which is
capital doesn't think bro and your
Revolution failed sorry well I mean
there's you you brought a lot up there
for my very limited delvings into the
Biograph biographical tradition of the
board there are different ways of
reading his domineering personality with
some think is his domineering
personality letting people into kicking
out people from this group of the S.I
the the situation is international one
way is to yeah read it negatively
reflecting on his personality being
being like a totalitarian or domineering
or or controlling of those around him
and the other one is that the more
charitable reason way to read it is to
say that he doesn't want the
situationist international to like
ossify into a group with dedicated
people who sort of follow it like a like
a movement he wants it I mean it never
ascended above say like 70 members and
he wanted them all to be dedicated but
not in a way like
I don't know maybe he was defining it
against stalinism or something not like
a party but just like a group of
talented and dedicated people who are
affiliated rather than
you know he was he was managing the
group in that way
so the biographical tradition yeah I
mean people are fighting in there it's
pretty it's pretty intense actually
still the debate over deboer's life and
did he have an incestuous relationship
with his half-sister or whatever what's
his personality like this is that whole
thing and then in what we're talking
about now in the first comment
you know I tried to look for the
explanation for that and not just jump
to oh he's like become increasingly
paranoid and that by the 80s he's so
he's so wary of of governments and
secret agents looking at him that he's
writing in this way
because immediately after in the second
paragraph of the first comment he says
our unfortunate times compel me once
again to write in a new way
so you look at his Society the spectacle
he's writing in a certain way aphoristic
Style apaditic
sets of Theses here he's saying now I'm
going to write in a new way because he's
he's fitting his style to fit something
he sees in this new development
the times right so you know he's
omitting things and he's not really
making a he's not he's not laying down
the plan it'll have to remain unclear I
don't know I I tried to read it as he's
just now like going through a change of
style and approach rather than it being
this weird paranoia people have read
here as well hey one of the changes is
he actually gives examples in this book
that's a pleasant change what do you
think do you do you know of any debord
scholar I don't I know don't know that
there are any but I wanna I wanna ask
them because he's basically saying here
in number one
you have to read this book like a Taylor
Swift song where there's a bunch of like
secrets
secrets to decode everywhere and I don't
know that is is that true in a Taylor I
didn't know that about Taylor Swift
that's a thing that's a thing oh really
well you you know anyone who knows me
knows where you can find me on a
Saturday night it's on the floor of my
bedroom sitting on the carpet cracking
open a t-swift jewel case and trying to
find out which Boy the song is about
that's that's I literally listen to No
top pop music I only listen to podcasts
look at you I'm saying I'm just saying I
don't listen to any [__] I don't listen
to anything I mean sometimes story time
I don't know my like my girlfriend
listens to like r b stuff and like maybe
some pop and like that's my little the
limitation of my exposure to anything
pop related in terms of Music in any
case do we need to decode this book or
do we just want to move on I think we're
too tired to decode it so you're gonna
have to sorry listener you're gonna have
to go to someone else or read it
yourself
Cal horror
was not some [__] that like Strauss
talked about right like the esoteric and
the exoteric reading of the text that
was like yeah but that would be in that
would be in any text and he's declaring
by the way there's a lot of secrets in
this book so you should you should read
it carefully he's actually telling us
that there's an esoteric reading of it
like whereas the the other ones didn't
say that explicitly
anyway
yeah yeah I'm just I'm really happy that
I'm a French Scholars can I can I just
say I'm excited that this is the end of
our engagement with the spectacle I I
feel
fatigued by this I I don't like I mean I
don't think that
I don't actually think
that I have like strong strong
disagreements other than the stuff I
said in like the beginning of the series
about the emancipatory potential that I
think he was implying I think that's all
kind of like bogus
but in terms of the account of the
spectacle like the as a description of
like social reality
I I I'm like pretty much on board I just
think there's maybe the theorists who
say it better who have more precise
distinctions in the way that they talk
about the media what the war calls the
spectacle so I'm just glad we're done
yeah yeah I know you are but you know
what part part and parcel with the
reason that you don't like this book you
can call it that that imprecision is
also probably the reason that it's so
adaptable and generally popular because
you can use this one pretty common basic
word spectacle to describe
all of media experience It's
Entertainment it's politics it's even
the technology that underlies it and
other theorists would maybe speak of
this part or that part of it
um Lacon and the imaginary is is
interesting to compare it to or well
in the scene or mcluhan's secondary
orality but none of these things you
know none of them have the same hit that
spectacle does because it just is yeah
it means all of it yeah mass media
capitalism right it's it's a way of
talking about late capitalism and what's
worse is it's a common word that we use
so it's gonna conflict in its meaning
especially if you don't read what the
spectacle is according to the board and
you use it as if it's got its dictionary
meaning yeah I mean the the spectacle
exactly like I think that's the thing
it's it's a term that's used for another
purpose already
yeah exactly exactly I really like other
Concepts like beaudryards you know hyper
real I think like that captures
something more specific and interesting
to me that I think is part of the
spectacle
I don't know if you guys would agree
that like
hyper real as you know again admittedly
I'm not that familiar with Beauregard
but you know through pill through
plastic pills videos I feel like I've
gotten a fairly decent idea of what it
is and maybe that would be like an
effect of the spectacle or how would you
fit that into what the spectacle is
I do want to say that because I've got
comments from the uh other people on our
series here that kind of make that
reference but there's a really important
distinction is that uh his beaudiard
criticizes the concept of the spectacle
so that's the first thing to note in um
Ecstasy of communication for example but
the hyperreal is different in that the
hyper real is where there are no
Originals anymore and it's very
important to Deborah that there is that
original because the real is Labor
Relations Labor Relations still exists
they haven't changed they're actually
getting worse and they're still there
Meanwhile we're in the spectacle yeah
it's tied to the commodity and the
spectacle is the other side of money in
a certain way it's it's tied to market
economies it's tied to a critique of
political economy in in ways that yeah
beaudryard leaves behind
um but that would be a line to draw
right like if you're a post-modern
theorist
then the simulation is completely
unmoored there's no determining there's
nothing behind it determining it it's
completely self-contained
to use like a really loose description
whereas the spectacle is still
reflecting the economic system that
we're under it's reflecting a new phase
of that economic system it's tied to
market economies and globalization and
mass media But ultimately he pins the
image
to the commodity and he's making use of
commodity fetishism and alienation
Marxist Concepts but but we don't you
know in that that stuff becomes
contested in the postmodern era
so I mean it's it it's it I think it's
that Marxist basis
um whereas and then and then
contemporary marxists seem to
leave the board out when they're going
through the the cannon right like Alphas
air is the big reference for this time
there's no debord as far as I see he
just gets moved into like cultural
Theory and people do like media studies
with his Concepts but they're not you
know they're not using him to orient
their interpretation of Marx in the same
way that you know Alpha Sarah does and
for good reason he wrote a lot more
stuff directly related to Marx than the
boards just kind of detouring Marx right
he's not really trying to say anything
about
capital or the critique of political
economy
well other people might not have talked
very much about him so he wrote another
book on himself
comments on this comments Otto's own
book and the whole thing is it actually
doubling down it's still full of all the
great pithy statements one of my
favorites is once the spectacle stops
talking about something for three days
it's like it never existed
and I'm like that's cute you thought it
was three days because ours yes ours is
like 46 24-hour news cycle that's what
it is that's what it is what's it
everyone's forgot about everyone's
forgot about climate change denial now
and we're all hopping on the happy train
together it's just we can't do anything
about it because of systemic issues man
but basically the book is doubling down
I'm actually using examples which is
Handy points to a lot of examples from
from the 80s especially in politics
um some of which I didn't understand
because it was about European politics
in the 80s Which is far from my area of
specialties
but he says I was right I was right I
was right I was right what do you think
about this I was right despite
1967 the first book coming right before
this failed Revolution
that was like pretty much everything
that the situationists could have hoped
for May 68 is the biggest publicist
situation and it didn't get any of the
psychological Awakening or the
Consciousness production that they hoped
for even though it looks to me like they
got pretty much everything they could
have wanted yeah
it sort of becomes another spectacle in
the in this sort of procession
of the development of the spectacle yeah
yeah I don't know I can't see what he
could be wrong about in a way because
yeah he does make a lot of those sort of
like very general statements
and it's difficult yeah that's the thing
is isn't that that might be like part of
my frustration with the whole way in
which the spectacle is framed and maybe
why I kind of find it boring uh is
because the claim seems to be so Broad
and so General that it's really hard to
tell if he's right or wrong or like
where he could be wrong
non-falsifiable non-falsifiable yeah
yeah to me like what makes exciting
philosophy or part of exciting
philosophy in my opinion is like when
it's a really interesting claim that I'm
like is that true and I can actually
think about it because this it's so
broad he just makes a general
description and I'm like yeah that kind
of seems right and then it's just like
not much else to think about it's kind
of boring I don't know I mean maybe this
gets back to like a more fundamental
issue about how you know the the air we
breathe or whatever fish and water it's
really hard to get a handle on like
what's going on now until many many
years later when a lot of its
consequences have fully unfolded the
then we could look back and get a clear
a clearer picture but now when when
we're swimming in that history of change
like it's really hard to get a sense of
like what the dominant Trends are you
know you think you've spotted some
dominant Trends and then something else
overtakes it and and how do you foresee
it like you can't making predictions is
difficult right but isn't it but isn't
the way that he's described this though
like the only way in which this could
not be true to some extent
would be if if we went back to like some
a narco primitivist Society or like no
or maybe that's two over and over
exaggeration
like that I don't know we would have to
like turn our backs on media technology
like completely which isn't going to
happen like as long as there's visual
media technology that is like having a
great effect on our culture then the
spectacle will always be true no only
when it's private and listen I'll let
only when it's private I'll let I'll let
him answer you because he answers you
as to the spectacle itself I was
sometimes accused of having invented it
out of thin air and was always accused
of indulging myself to access in my
evaluation of its depth and unity and
its real workings I must admit that
others who later publish new books on
the same subject demonstrated that it
was possible to say less
all they had to do was replace the
totality and its movement by a single
static detail on the surface of the
phenomenon which each with each author
demonstrating his originality by
choosing a different and all the less
disturbing one no one wanted to taint
the scientific modesty of his imper of
his personal interpretation by
interposing Reckless historical
judgments
so I think what he's kind of suggesting
is you have to think of this thing as a
totality not as the whole world but a
totalization of every private experience
and if you try this is again
he's got a hugely inflated ego I mean
that's my the way that I understand it
he's like there's no way that I could be
wrong because the only thing that I can
talk about is the whole thing at once as
a giant historical
tumor that we're all stuck inside and if
you want to talk about this detail or
that detail then you're just trying to
make yourself feel better by making the
problem less than it is so I don't know
maybe true maybe not oh this is this is
like Luke Koch and the publication of
the gurundresa as well right the idea of
totality you have to look at the whole
system like you know Mar like Marx's
full Capital right we often just read
volume one and then think it's all about
production relations when later he's
going to talk about you know markets and
Banking and interest and and all that so
but we leave that stuff out because a
you know this two more [__] massive
volumes and B he died and they're edited
a lot a lot of it especially the third
volume is is a little bit not put
together in the final form maybe that
Marx would have done it Engels is good
faith
editing but he wasn't marks
but anyway for one reason or other it's
a little one-sided sometimes what's
hilarious about Deborah is that he said
Marx almost ruined Marxism by writing
all of that stuff
because and he's the reason for this was
that Marx alienated himself or I
shouldn't say alienated because it's a
technical term but he isolated himself
in in the British library or whatever he
left the working class and started
trying to defend himself against all
these critiques and then his his system
became
over intellectualized scientific Marxism
as opposed to his earlier humanist stuff
he says this became overly
intellectualized and became an obstacle
to later Marxist movements so
interesting and you have that and there
you have that sort of people trying to
stake a claim on what part of Marx is
the best
which is to me a completely futile and
and
fruitless Endeavor is say what's better
late marks early marks is there
continuity is there rupture I mean oh my
God I don't know I I don't know about
any of that Marx who studied in the
library of London because London was the
most advanced Center of capital in the
world at the time and had an
extraordinary set of resources for him
to look through and more than any place
on the planet at that time so I don't
understand that critiquing him for
writing capital in the best place in the
whole world you could possibly write
that book okay yeah I'm gonna go I'm
gonna write about Canada but I'm gonna
go do it on Mars because I I like to
like what the [__] is that I don't
understand that but yeah okay early Marx
is better humanist Marxism okay I get
where he's coming from I just don't
really care
at least he takes a position a strong
position so one thing I wanted to
compare this to
um as kind of a defense of him actually
I know I've been shooting on his huge
head but uh he's very doctrinally
consistent about I think what you'd call
The Organic intellectual and if he never
brings it up it's it's uh what's his
name gram she's con idea
concept of the organic intellectual that
is like connected to the people the
majority and all that as opposed to the
Intelligentsia and the board very
clearly does not want to be an
intellectual he clearly doesn't want to
be a philosopher an academic this kind
of thing that we're used to reading so I
this might be part of Victor's aversion
to the style because it's
non-falsifiable sort of Manifesto like
it's meant
to be read by pretty much anyone anyone
could read it and like beam their own
life onto the page in a sense but do you
think that that helps at all or are you
just saying I'm a I'm a philosopher so I
want a philosophy book that's given me
falsifiable claims leading to a thesis
with a conclusion that I can actually
engage with but do you think it's
helpful that he's doing this public
intellectual thing
yeah I mean I I don't actually have a
problem with it I like I even said that
I broadly agree with a lot of the
account I just it might be it's I think
it's just a question of personal taste
uh I I don't enjoy this kind of full I
actually have no problem with manifestos
either though because I think manifestos
can be interesting to engage with but I
do have issue with like the
non-falsifiability of it I you know I
have an issue I have a similar issue
with the way that Foucault talks about
power sometimes also just like I don't
uh
uh I my eyes start to glaze over when
the a theorist is pushing forward a
concept that just applies to so many
things where I feel like what are the
interesting distinctions
uh I think Foucault does make a lot more
distinctions than debord so I actually
do find Foucault interesting in a lot of
places but
yeah I mean I take that point uh
wait where this is going to take us a
little bit off topic but just because
you brought it up aren't you kind of
mistaking the fucos conclusion for the
way he got to his conclusion because
it's
very empirical it's very empirical the
way he gets there through studying like
the clinic or the prison yeah yeah
tracing the evolution of of those ideas
you know he's a historian this is the
thing the spectacle takes away from us
as our history you're right you're right
actually so that so that is actually a
huge difference because I think the
conclusion is more yeah is more the
thing that I could compare with whereas
it feels like Deborah doesn't even do
all that work to get to the conclusion
the Foucault does yeah he gives us we
covered this last week he gives us a
four-page summary of all of human
history to this point
exactly exactly but I mean I I mean I
don't mean I don't want to drive us too
off topic but if we were to get rid of
like as long as we have some kind of
visual media we're going to be in the
spectacle and you guys I think both said
well only if it's
like privately owned or functioning and
I guess that seems a little puzzling to
me because
like it has to be more than just who
owns it right
media is fair game for the spectacle as
well exactly well I didn't I didn't mean
private in terms of who owns it rather
private in its consumption
okay because he says
he says there's two kinds of like
responses to public art or we could just
let's just call it content because art
brings all these associations there's
two uh ways to do content and one is
publicly and if you do it publicly then
you create a crowd as a corollary to it
but that crowd is Unified they're
together
um I think you could maybe a movie
theater would be a good example like a
the gear you are all there experiencing
it together as opposed to if everyone's
watching TVs isolatedly in their own
homes then you have a crowd but it's a
crowd of individuals as opposed to a
crowd with its own
um organicism
so when he's talking before he wrote The
Society of spectacle when he's talking
about the layout of cities the layout of
cities decides what kind of crowd you
get public art decides what kind of
crowd you get so I think he'd be very in
favor of
um art forms like a mural Maybe
as a public art or or I don't I don't
know but whatever we're doing here like
letting people consume through their
headphones this is the opposite of what
he would have uh espoused I think
oh so that's what you meant by private
and public you meant just like the the
the the
uh right the method with which the media
is being consumed or like the the form
um
I'm not I'm not getting the right word
but yeah like so so if you're the
phenomenology of it if you will yeah
yeah the phenomenology of it so if
you're doing it as an individual then
that's becoming the spectacle but like
could you imagine like not having any of
that like not having any private
consumption like is that like what does
that even look like no and that's
probably part of the point yeah but but
I guess like when were people only
consuming publicly I I guess when we had
no technology
no May 68
oh okay this was my original things like
he you got it you got it the year after
you wrote the book you got your chance
to okay so we can we have moments that
was a situation right the situationists
yeah the the 68 was a situation but it
quickly gets folded back into spectacle
yeah he also talks about the Watts Riots
in an earlier writing as Eric were at a
couple weeks ago but here's a here's a
good question to what extent or to what
degree is a riot a form of public art
yeah those are those are like eruptions
of of the like discontents but they have
to erupt in the context of spectacle
like you can't there's no other context
right even like you look at this podcast
right like we're yeah yeah okay we we do
this for free and we dabble with
crowdfunding but in a sense this is all
extension of Commodities these images
sound images visual images whatever
we're doing there are extensions of
Commodities in the market right all the
products we use our crowdfunding
platform our streaming platforms like
everything is this is all commodity
imagery like it this wouldn't exist
without
without that spectacle
being a kind of I I don't know I don't
it's not an Epi phenomenon because it
contains real in it it's not just an Epi
phenomenon of the market it's a it's an
evolution of it
so even what we're doing here like even
though we you know we do it for quote
unquote free
for donation for donations but you know
be being honest yeah yeah we're we're
we're constructing we're producing
images for consumption in a Marketplace
we wouldn't exist without it
I don't think you can escape it but you
know what you're saying earlier about
um yeah his personal or it's like our
the way he puts his claims out I think
for me what makes me if I had enough
more time want to study the spectacle as
the board puts it is because it seems it
feels like it speaks to me on a level of
like my discontent right like I hate
living in a market Society where all of
the you know
all of the dignified and and and all of
the best you know deeds and emotions and
things that humans are all reduced to
profit consumption
commercials advertisements like I hate
that world
you know advertising determines our
behaviors and our desires and our the
way we use language and you know I can't
think of love or friendship without a
movie or a [__] Hallmark or something
like that right all these profit
Endeavors all these corpse businesses
like I I just I don't know the spectacle
speaks to me a fundamental level of my
discontent with the world around me no
that's good I mean I think that's
actually a useful insight to have
um and that's also
kind of always been my sort of Suspicion
not suspicions not the right word but
kind of my hunch about why this work
speaks to some people and not to others
and this might even be kind of true of
other sorts of thinkers theorists in
this realm
is it speaking to your discontent
um and I have a feeling
um based on my kind of cursory look at
our Discord that there are a lot of
people who uh the board speaks to their
discontents and therefore it is an
appealing
approach yeah yeah and then I don't know
then going beyond that to assess the
quality of the arguments like I don't
know it doesn't seem like he's written
it for that to be done to it
and it's it's its seductiveness is is
based on I think when you're when you
agree with what he's saying already in a
certain sense not like preaching to the
choir but when you sort of already are
thinking on that wavelength of you know
there's something fundamentally wrong
here with the world he he gives you a
way of articulating it and it helps that
he's an amazing stylist of Pros he's a
really like it's hard to deny that he's
a great writer it's just what he's
saying is is what we're kind of having
trouble with yeah and you know
interestingly like I don't actually
think I disagree like I've been saying
with with the broad picture uh I just
think it's kind of boring okay let me
let me bring up here he says there's one
thing
really only one only one that needs to
be updated in 20 years okay
um I love this cover by the way do you
guys have this one I don't the big the
cover of Victor is showing us very
disrespectfully to the listeners the
audio audience is one where they have
the 3D or the fake glasses on very
common one look at what look at this one
it's just the words that was like a film
in the 40s or 50s
um where everybody's sitting in rows
yeah the first 3D glasses film
and it's yeah he it was chosen for one
of the early covers of society the
spectacle this is so weird though my
addition doesn't have page numbers it
has the aphorism numbers but no page
numbers not that I guess that matters
anyway sorry my book has a New Yorker
comment on the back which I think is
good enough reason to throw it out
anyway the one thing that needs to be
changed
he says on a theoretical level I only
need to add a single detail to my
earlier formulation albeit one that has
far-reaching consequences yeah I was
gonna say it's a pretty big detail yeah
he's like he says in 67 there's two
types of spectacle One belongs to
America and americanism which is the
diffuse spectacle I mean meaning that
it's it's everywhere it's a whole bunch
of private corporations there's no like
Central organizing feature to it and
then the other type of spectacle is
uh stalinism and maoism which is called
concentrated spectacle
which we would probably call in sort of
Normie economic terms like free market
capitalists and like centralized or
planned economy capitalism but he
basically says maoism is a personality
call everyone has to be obsessed with
MAO you can't criticize Mao you get the
book The Red Book and all that stuff so
they have their own spectacle he's just
as critical of that side of it as uh the
American side of it and the one detail
he wants to add which is not a detail
it's a huge distinction is to add that
we also have integrated spectacles and
for him the integrated spectacle
describes just the middle of those
other two things which is for him or it
makes use of both in the 80s it's uh
France and Italy are the examples that
that he gives
they they've they implemented the the um
I I don't know what his reference here
is but yeah they somehow implemented
this integrated
spectacle which makes use of both and
they say he says it he says it it um
the integrated spectacles both diffuse
and what was the other one concentrated
I'll just read the quotation the
integrated spectacle shows itself to be
simultaneously concentrated and diffused
and ever since the fruitful Union of the
two has learned to employ both these
qualities on a grander scale the former
mode of application has changed
considerably as regards concentration
the controlling Center has now become a
cult never to be occupied by a known
leader or a cure or a clear ideology
so the point of it I suppose is to have
you you don't have the concentration in
like a single personality cult but I
think you could apply this to something
like a neoliberal party would be the
example is we have a spectacle there's a
right wing and a left wing but the left
wing is like the DNC for example so
that's your your choice is fake
and
it's not completely diffuse because
you're not allowed to have any other or
no no opinions really count right
there's no left wing in in the United
States for example and in the in the
French government in the 80s it's just
like the co the Communist party is
withering away
and not in the way that Marx intended
but it's withering away and being
replaced by this like uh leftist Social
Democrat kind of kind of party
it's almost like he's saying it's
schizophrenic
in a certain in the in the sense of of
of being of like sort of
being able to live with two
contradictory ways of approaching the
world
centralized and autocratic like the way
Western countries tend to treat you know
non-western or developing countries but
then it can also be very diffuse and
sort of not authoritarian and kind like
Western countries treat their own people
exactly or like within the same
political system having Democrats and
Republicans right like one's the diffuse
party the other one's the concentrated
party but they're both they're both
they're both corporate capitalist
parties there there's there's no
difference between them except in their
presentation well the point is they're
functionally interchangeable right like
and whether the conservatives or the
Liberals are in charge of Canada it
makes very little difference but you
unlike in a concentrated spectacle where
it's like Mao is the guy everything is
good if it's Mao but then Mao also has
to take blame for everything that goes
wrong right and in a in an integrated
spectacle
you know
Bill Clinton gets a blow job you get rid
of him the next guy comes in so it's
always like it's a it's an office
that you can never really associate with
an individual the individual becomes a
momentary pinata when something goes
wrong but then you replace it so you
never get to what's actually in charge
what's actually running the system how
much does It ultimately cost to become
president who's uh who do you gotta get
on your knees for to be even in that
office but the integrated spectacle is
you never really know who's in charge
but it but it still gives you something
to direct your hate at you can hate
something for two minutes and then it
disappears yeah you know I mean that
kind of that sort of makes me feel like
there's never actually been a truly
diffused spectacle
like like so it seems to me that you you
do have examples of concentrated
spectacle because you have had like like
brutally authoritarian
like regimes but I don't know has like a
truly like purely Market oriented like
con like like context ever actually
existed like I feel like it's always
been
um
like integrative
well this is kind of where the spectacle
becomes stupid because the spectacle
applies to entertainment and to politics
and to news and this is an it's another
point that he makes is that all these
things are interconnected in the
integrated spectacle because a financier
a financier's daughter can become a
singer he just pays for it basically a a
lawyer can become a police spy a
football player can become a politician
overnight uh as we are seeing we're
seeing that each of these aspects of the
spectacle are just completely
interchangeable all you need is
Celebrity Status once your celebrity
status you can become a you can start
have a startup or you can be a fashion
icon or you can be a politician and I
could fill that in with examples but I'm
sure I don't even need to go that far so
all these things are integrated but I
think you're right in that like if is it
as applied to politics which is what he
wants to do half of half of the time
uh it doesn't make sense to really talk
about a diffuse spectacle but when it
comes to something like advertising or
the advertising space that that is a
diffuse spectacle that is just objects
with with no Center nothing to do with
each other all vying for your attention
at exactly the same time
it's probably worth mentioning the
definition he chooses for this piece as
well because we kind of had a bit of an
issue with that in the society because
he says so many different things about
it at so many different places and they
all say like the spectacle is this and
here he just says it's the autocratic
reign of the market economy in in
section two there he says it's the
autocratic reign of the market economy
that's what it is the market economy
come to dominate globally he said and he
continues on which has acceded to an
irresponsible sovereignty
and and
I guess this is another part of the
definition and it's the totality of new
techniques of government which
accompanied this reign
so new techniques of government and
dominance of a market economy and new
techniques in response to that
domination or bringing about that
domination a little less clear but uh
yeah yeah that's what it is so there's a
there's a diffuse style of market
economy and there's a connected style of
techniques of governments and I guess
those diffuse and concentrated
techniques again are just both available
now in the integrated spectacle as well
as
you know advertising I don't know what a
concentrated form of like a market
economy would be I guess you'd I guess
it would be like like East Berlin before
the fall of the wall something like that
what a more like a planned economy again
with our decisions and our tax money are
going towards exploiting dangerous
underwater stores like anyway you can
pile up the examples yeah there's so
much concentrated we think we live in a
free market economy a diffuse economy
well really no there's there's a huge
core of these decisions that that nobody
got to make except out of necessity in
some situation whatever building
highways for the war whatever it is you
know cars right you know you live in a
suburb you drive a car no [__] Choice
that's it I like to use public transit
too bad it's [__] here and the lobbies
of the car companies have been [__]
the government over whenever they want
to improve it anyway so okay there's
there's a mix of concentrated and
diffuse by the way you can go out and
buy whatever brand of beer you want so
cool cool there's a diffusion for you
yeah you're way too concerned with the
real man you just you have a choice you
can watch NBC
or CNN or Fox News
yeah there you go you can read National
Post or CBC yeah really they all run
like the same sort of sets of stories
every day it seems it's kind of like
both choice and no choice put together
whichever one needs to be put forward
that's the one that serves whatever
rhetorical purpose of the moment
yeah I mean it makes sense to me I I
like that distinction to be honest it
adds a little bit
to you know the spectacle yeah the
spectacles got these different forms
and
then they eventually become integrated
okay certain places practice one or the
other four more and then globe and then
it becomes globalized and kind of
integrated and appears in both forms
without a kind of logic
it can appear within democracies
concentrated whatever yeah I kind of
like that I mean it adds a bit of meat
to it anyway and if it's the autocratic
regime of the market and the techniques
of government okay and I think both
you're I mean really it's almost like
two ends of a spectrum with no such
point in history ever reaching either
end
and you just have like different points
on that Spectrum where they're kind of
closer to being diffused or closer to
being concentrated and which is the same
as free and planned Market anyway
there's never been a free or a planned
economy but but
now it seems like the point is I guess
that it it just swerves more there's no
way you know you find you know
bureaucratic capitalism in China you
find you know more kind of liberal
capitalism in other places but it can
appear in either form within those
contexts anyway it doesn't make a
difference in the integrated spectacle
so much yeah one thing I'd caution
against though is this is not about
the spectacle is not about actual
economies and who owns what it's always
about what is said about actual
economies and what is said about who
owns what are those common examples is
like Western media will use as an
example of how free and liberal it is
point to how extremely
censored and controlled Chinese media is
for for an example all the time I mean I
mean they are they also just control
they have like a median like State
controlled media that yeah that's a
consistent message so it's centralized
but what Deboer is saying is being being
diffuse makes it no less subject to
ideology production than being
centralized it's exactly the same thing
in the end well I mean I think there's
you can make an argument for like why
the difference could be relevant but in
terms of just whether or not you're in
well first of all you just can't ever
escape the spectacle so what difference
does it really make from that
perspective sure
I also agree with Jack and just thinking
that's ideology is a spontaneous uh kind
of production of human subjectivity so
you can't escape ideology regardless of
what context you're in but there is a
real outside and the
private interests determine what are the
talking points of the day
so you it doesn't like it doesn't matter
which which
what's funding Fox News because once Fox
News says it then CNN news responds to
Fox News and they do a news report on
the other people's news report so it
doesn't matter if you're that you're not
bringing up fossil fuel industry
corruption or the negligence of of the
the people they're in it doesn't matter
that you never have to bring those up
because it's censored by the very Act of
the production of the news which is news
on news and you have to talk about the
same thing that the other the other
network is talking about so that you
never talk about the real so even if
it's like a contingent or unconscious
avoidance of anything that he calls the
real of any questions of ownership
it doesn't really matter because it's
just words on both sides and words on
Words and words reacting two words
which like I always say when John Oliver
does those like uh news Roundup Clips on
on Last Week Tonight and he plays all
the different news stations saying the
exact same thing like like 20 30 40
different ones and they're all saying
almost exactly the same lines all the
way up from like the news stories to the
little silly things like it's uh I don't
know it's it's it's pumpkin latte time
at your at the at lot at Starbucks again
they all say that at the same time of
the year
yeah they are they're commenting on each
other I I agree with that I just think
that I'll always kind of resist the
suggestion that like there's no
difference between like a context in
like a Chinese like authoritarian regime
and a liberal Democratic one like I
agree with the broad thing that there's
a kind of self-reinforcing influence but
like one obvious difference is if we
were in China our podcast couldn't exist
I mean there are residual differences
but I don't know like like again that's
like those differences have been broken
down for that to such a large degree
yeah like the invitation needed you're
saying you think that our podcast where
we could just say whatever we want and
gain an audience could just would be
naturally allowed to evolve unmolested
in China yeah
it's small and it's about obscure
philosophy oh we can say it well okay
but that's a huge difference well we
have to watch our jobs right we can't we
can't can't criticize people or dude you
declared with absolute self-assured
certainty that this podcast couldn't
exist in China and I asked you for a
citation and then you asked what I think
the citations needed from you that the
CCP even in China gives a [__] about
what three guys with four or five
thousand listeners think because I do
not believe it's that totalitarian but
I'm willing to be proven wrong I think
it's fair before I just get fun I'll
look it up right now hold on we we
talked before and we we agreed there are
certain things we can't discuss right
like we can't name names we can't we
shouldn't talk to specifically about
certain things going on at our jobs
right we are not free that freedom is
just rerouted in a slightly different
way we can't say whatever we want on
this podcast and then whatever whether
it's just moral considerations or
worries about censorship and and formal
reprisal I mean yeah there's a
difference there I mean I just wouldn't
equate those two things like like I mean
if there's
someone who
you know there might be certain things
where we don't want to like take a
chance uh or like personal relationships
that we don't want to talk about
publicly
I mean that seems way different than a
centralized government Authority that's
like monitoring communication and
deciding what's like in the interests of
the regime or not in in like in the
interest of the regime like there's no
there's no like monitoring by
centralized government authorities who
are checking to make sure we're not
saying anything
that they don't like different I mean
for the most part we can say anything
about the culture about politicians
about public figures
without any anxiety how is it that you
think China is like that
or that China would ever act that way
towards a podcast with 5K listens per
episode you need evidence for a claim
like that because otherwise you're just
repeating an opinion that you got from
the national post-diffuse spectacle and
I'm just saying my suspicion is that's
[__] unless you have evidence
because most of what our news says about
China is at best a half-truth well look
at right right now okay so so if your
standard is going to be like any media
any reporting on China and like that's
and you're just gonna dismiss that as
always being influenced by like Western
propaganda then I mean then we can't
really have a conversation about it I
asked you I said provide me your
citation you said I'll look for it and
you didn't bring it up I have I mean I
have an article here that's talking
about like China's podcasters are wary
of censorships as their popularity grows
from
uh I don't know where this is from South
China Morning Post let's see navigating
China's podcast censorship is Asia
central
well let's see here I think there might
have been something about Apple
uh
well look what's happening to
journalists right now in Russia right
like there's people who are going to
prison Maria
panorakenko sentenced to six years in
prison for her War reporting right now
okay like okay so Russia is cracking
down I some think some other person just
got in was it in in Iraq or something I
don't want to say the wrong place but
they got arrested for a Instagram post
that they put up right and the
government's cracking down
and here's a guardian article that's
saying uh you know Apple removing
podcasts uh at the best of the Chinese
government
you know we could find similar examples
here we may have to reach around a
little bit but okay like who's who's
being deported from England right now to
America to stand trial for certain
things they've said right there's
somebody that that's happening to
like these things happen in all contexts
it's not specific to China or Russia it
just depends on the situation there's
Wars and conflicts going on I'm not I'm
not saying they're cracking down on that
I'm not saying that there's not
Authority that we can argue and
criticize which we by the way have full
freedom to do that happen in Western
countries I'm not saying that I'm what
I'm saying is what I'm resisting is
making an equivalence being like these
things are the same
it's all basically the same spectacle
it's all basically I'm like no no
there's actually like real substantive
difference that have an impact on our
life and uh I just like I'll always
resist people who will just be like it's
all the same [__] it's all centralized
power like it's not it's not at all well
that's fine if it's a point like that
and that's not very nuanced it's about
making distinct no what I'm saying is
what I'm actually calling for is more
Nuance like I think there can be this
this move by people who are sympathetic
to kind of like left left-wing politics
where they want to kind of say I'm not
necessarily saying you're doing this
pills but just just kind of being like
yeah yeah it's I mean everyone's you
know controlling and censoring and I
think it's actually worth being nuanced
and making distinctions well what kind
of censorship what kind of Freedom do
you have uh what are like substantive
risks in one context versus another you
can actually talk about them and make
meaningful distinctions I don't know
that's not a meaningful distinction
until which neither of us has until we
have the list of how many podcasts have
been pulled in each country and I mean
those pulled by Apple podcasts or Google
or Spotify
but that isn't even what you said
because all you said was for sure we
wouldn't be allowed to do this podcast
if we were in China
well let me round this up and bring it
back to the text because what we seem to
be
kind of stopped at right now is is is
the spectacle a homogeneous
kind of phenomenon is it is it globally
homogeneous
and I I think the answer is probably
what you're saying is no there are
different things that happen in
different real places in the world
geographically it's not all floating in
some nowhere land of the spectacle there
are real distinctions where and when you
say things different things can happen
to you it's their context is still
important in the spectacle okay that's
that's fine yeah that's that's a that's
an important point I don't know if if he
addresses that here I think the
integrated spectacle is maybe looking
forward maybe we're running too far
ahead of what he's saying by making
those claims by saying you know it's the
same I could criticize Xi Jinping in
China I can criticize Biden in the
states exactly the same nothing will
happen to me okay well yeah no maybe not
right that's probably not the case but I
think it's pointing forward just like
when we look back we've seen maybe a
liberalization of those countries and an
acceptance of you know we're we're far
past the cultural revolution where you
could go to political prison for like
winking the wrong way at a polit at an
official but now and then the integrated
spectacle may be pointing forward to a
point where there's less of that like
where context seems to matter less or at
least spectacle is the context and it's
not geographically determined or
culturally determined
and like the main point that he's making
in saying that it's all the same is that
effectually it's all the same he's not
talking about one individual might be
arrested as opposed to another
individual saying the same thing
somewhere else they might not be
arrested but if you want to call it
global market capitalism anywhere the
effect is is the same whether you're in
China or in Los Angeles yeah like
there's maybe a developmental tendency
in the same direction but there's no
Erasure of those differences
maybe maybe they're kind of
being contested
like you know nah I don't know I I I
can't go too much further down this line
because I don't have enough of the board
here to kind of even predict how it
would respond I mean I look I I think
it's that's fair I just think it's weird
to be like blind to like some very
specific differences in terms of quality
of life and like for example your
ability to be creative and be critical
for your ability to like mock things and
make fun of things
like I mean in China like there were
those people who were comparing Xi
Jinping to like Winnie the Pooh and they
were getting [__] arrested and [__]
because they thought it was funny yeah
like that's I mean that's that's like
that's like a berries and like
you know on a podcast where I think we
value mocking and making fun of things I
think like that's well I think it would
be hard to do that a similar thing in
China if you're doing it about any
people in positions of authority you can
do that here you can do that here
definitely but you have to do it
differently right like you know you cut
you you say something about Trump and he
does a slap suit right that's how he
censors his uh I mean he could try he
could try but slap suits [__] people
over those are not something to be you
know I mean
I mean how many people have actually has
he sent a slap suit up I mean he was
speaking
he was getting mercilessly mercilessly
made fun of all the time and and like a
vast majority of those people and I'm
pretty sure most of those lawsuits got
got thrown out pretty quickly because of
anti-slops I want to I want you to apply
your own logic to China not because I
know anything about China but you're
like this is so widespread they're gonna
be listening to a podcast of this size
if we criticize you pick no we could
probably exist there absolutely fine
because we're not on ions the Winnie the
Pooh thing got on the radar because it
was like international news and every
every Western diffuse spectacle wanted
to be like look at how unfree they they
are over there and then you repeating
the point is the only thing that I'm
objecting to because I want evidence of
how repressive is it it was not like we
wouldn't be affected even if we were in
that situation that's yeah it's possible
it's possible that we wouldn't be
affected for for the first while I I
just think that yeah there is there's a
risk there's like so you know if we want
to continue to grow the audience like
that risk is always going to be in the
background the bigger audience we get
will start to feel a bit more anxious
right like we don't have to worry about
that now that may that's a real
difference I concede to the point that
we have zero risk and they have some
yeah there is a there is a sense in
which we do hang on to our diffuseness
here in the west and our freedom here in
the west but I think overall in the
totality of the spectacle and the
integrated spectacle there is a way in
which maybe we could say the diffuse
Parts tend to reinforce the
concentratedness of the concentrated
parts and vice versa the concept the the
diffuse Parts use the concentrated parts
to Define themselves and thereby make
those concentrated Parts react and the
concentrated parts do the same thing to
the diffuse Parts like what Russia does
in the news with all that disinformation
and and funding both sides of a
controversy right like the concentrated
Parts can then [__] with the diffuse
Parts but it's all taking place on the
same field right and we're not playing
different sports anymore we're on the
same pitch playing the same Sports and
it's not even two sides the two sides
are mixed
yeah I agree I agree with that that's
why he says the integrated the
integrated one
is the best and not the best for us
obviously but he says it is the best
it's the most globally adopted it's it's
and you can freeze a third form it's the
third form now of Frieza and that these
conflicts like the war in the Ukraine
and the and the looming economic war
with China do have a way of clarifying
the differences between the context in a
way that we just don't give a [__] about
when we're not in a conflict with some
other huge nation into this on this
scale right like the war in Syria has
not really gotten the same attention
you know one one billion dollars of Aid
being requested for 50 000 people dying
versus the 4 billion now being requested
in the Ukraine for about the same maybe
less people who are being displaced why
the difference
I don't know I don't know maybe it has
something to do with that racism the
news is pointing out a year or two ago
with the the Middle Eastern refugees
versus the Ukrainian refugees but
I actually wanted to talk about one more
thing if that's possible because I think
this is related to what we've been
talking about and that is his seeming
end of History argument he makes
um and in section four then in section
six he starts to bring up this like end
of History the spectacular domination's
first priority was this is historical I
guess now first priority was to
eradicate historical knowledge the 24
news cycle thing we were talking about
now is being implemented and he's
pointing this out in section six he
makes an end of History argument in a
sense right whereas any kind of Compares
this in the ancient Greeks right like
Herodotus and thucydides their their
theory of History was to preserve for
all time these great deeds and events of
Greeks and non-greeks in whatever the
Persian Wars whatever the to preserve
for posterity at all time immortalize
these things in in our historical
writings now
he uses that as a point of contrast to
spectacle however does not want a
history it wants almost like a Perpetual
present
where in France some 10 years since now
a president of the Republic long ago
forgotten but at the time still basking
on the spectacle's surface naively
expressed his Delight in knowing that
henceforth we believe in a world without
memory where images flow and merge like
Reflections on the water
so the end of History gives power a
welcome break he says and success is
guaranteed in all its undertakings so
our short Collective memory the
spectacles erasing our memory it's a bit
of a pharmacon
in this way
um a bit of a in in Dairy does sense
um I looked for that citation by the way
where because I was like this is great
where the the president is apparently
talking about memory floating away we
live in a time without memory and
speaking of it positively because I
assume he was talking about mirror on
probably
I couldn't find any any citation
I think he probably made it up or he or
he was doing the podcast thing where you
just cite something from memory because
I couldn't find any reference to that
except from this book oh again he's he's
doing the Greek thing making [__] up
citing from memory to hear saying
stories yeah I mean it's it's an end of
History argument what is like like
fukiyama's is made about a year after
this is it like a year yeah if we can
imagine 89 or 90 I forgot it was like
right after the fall of the Soviet Union
yeah once once it's clear like it
doesn't fall officially until 92 I think
yeah he writes the end of History the
victory of liberal capitalism here we
have the victory of the now the
integrated spectacle emerging in in his
thinking which is kind of interesting an
interesting parallel there the so so the
victory of liberal capitalism in
fukuyama which which to be fair he later
revises but at this point this is coming
out soon and Deport is is is before the
fact predicting a kind of end of history
but not I guess not on the basis of the
fall of the Communist regime's most uh
prized prized Nation yeah when I when I
was reading this I was like
because I mean in a sense it's expected
because news is not about
it's not called olds it's about what's
new
but could you imagine if like Anderson
Cooper ever gave historical context to
any of the story of the day I think that
would be shocking because the whole
thing I mean unconsciously and perhaps a
little bit consciously as the board is
is expecting the news is meant to
dominate all media consumption Tire you
out from it never reference anything
about history because if you thought
about history you might think about how
things could have been different how
things could have gone a different way
instead of justifying the the status quo
completely but can you I yeah I was
thinking we have we do have diverse
enough media through you know podcasting
and YouTube and independent creators but
I you you will very very rarely if ever
hear
a
something near the center of the
spectacle bring up historical
justifications or examples except for
the pure purpose of like jingoism
talking about Abraham Lincoln or
defeating the Nazis maybe those are the
vague references they make but nothing
that happens today is ever a result of
something that happened in the past
yeah or we we never make that connection
here his examples are book burning here
he talks about book burning in the in
the I guess in the concentrated regimes
of say like was he saying and sinche
Huang TI had book burnings in our own
Century Stalin went further
yet despite the various accomplices that
remain in area of the world beyond the
reach of his police
okay no memory we're not allowed to have
a kind of like Collective historical
memory
I don't know maybe maybe we feel that in
in North America because of our Colonial
past we don't tend to talk about it as
much any time it but we were forced to
talk about it it's so [__]
contentious and the News wants to run it
for as little time as possible because
it's not very politically
um beneficial to be discussing this in a
white Colonial settler Nation
um it's not doesn't get you political
brownie points to talk about the plight
of indigenous people and and former
slaves and and any marginalized people
here so we're encouraged to have a short
memory book burnings I don't know you
could probably lump the leftist pulling
statues down and like pulling down
statues of Confederates
and similar acts on the right you could
lump that in symbolic destruction of
History we don't want to have any of it
anymore what is it what what's he doing
with that it's kind of weird how's that
part of the spectacle I don't think
because the spectacle isn't burning
books the spectacle isn't
toppling statues or refusing to talk
about the past but he says there's a the
spectacle has acquired through this
advantage through the outlawing of
History it's outlawed history
not because of the victory of of of
Western liberal capitalism but because
it's just been banished and of course
it's not officially outlawed either it
just by the functioning
of its technical properties you don't
need to banish it you just haven't have
more Tick Tock than than history and he
doesn't it's odd he doesn't say anything
as like like because I want to say
something simplistic and just be like
yeah because there's just always new
news to replace the old news like so how
can we keep all this [__] in our head
but he doesn't say anything like that
his his point is that the usurpers he
says quote have shared this aim to make
us forget that they have only just
arrived the usurpers
being I'm assuming the bureaucratic
capitalist class because they have only
just arrived maybe in historical terms
you know 19th century
Industrial Revolution creates the
factory owners because obviously there's
no factories before then so how the [__]
could there be Factory owners there's
whatever this Bourgeois new new class
has only just arrived I'm assuming
that's what he's talking about merged
with
governments and made bureaucratic
regimes and oligarchies
but they are new they're new people
they're new people we had I don't know
I'm filling in gaps here in my head
there's you know the old bear like the
The Rockefellers and and all those
people who made their money in in in
steel and building Railways and
electrifying America
et cetera et cetera the sort of the sort
of um
productivist billionaires now there's
the new ones who have who have only just
just arrived which are the tech
billionaires who were working more
Downstream from those older folks
um who are employing us all and recently
firing us all Tesla whose star seems to
be fading and others like that anyway I
just want to bring that up because that
seems to be what we were also like the
differences between uh context and
censorship we were talking about seems
to also go hand in hand because it's
near that section of of the end of
History the end of History May mean the
end of those sorts of contexts so maybe
he's a bit ahead of himself here
um that's all I want to say anyway yeah
I I personally have never experienced
this level of focus on the podcast
before talking about the same thing for
so many weeks at a time
um it's been nice and sobering but I
think we're going to move on now thank
God stay tuned for next episode
let's do masculinity next I saw that on
the list like the manosphere and
masculinity yeah let's do that God
so much more interesting well I picked
this one so I guess you get the next
pick Victor but isn't it on the list it
was it was on it was on the patron list
for sure they they suggested I'd say
just uh I want I want the bet I'm gonna
decide based on the reading I have no
problem talking about them masculinity
but
I'm just the what kinds of readings
would be I have some good ones actually
questions I have a good psychoanalytic
book actually that we could read like a
chapter from
uh
so listener if you've missed while we
decide I don't know why we're doing this
now
while we while we decide on our next
topic masculinity has been suggested and
now it's been publicly suggested so I
don't know how well you could edit this
out I don't know if we do a series or a
single one but anyway if you missed any
any of our month and a half or two
months on the spectacle and situationism
which was the last group of people that
I know of that saw a purpose of public
art or a purpose of art at all besides
you know parking Investments and
changing social Consciousness rather
naively we we see in hindsight but the
last people to do that if you've missed
any of that all the episodes are on the
patron and with that we confine this to
history and history is dead
thank God
last comments last comment on the
comment of History how many times
because I watched um Good Morning
America I think I have to do a live
stream on this I watched Good Morning
America the day after the Super Bowl and
they are obsessed with making history
it's like two black quarterbacks played
against each other we made history and
two brothers on different sides making
history it's like there's because
there's no history there's this
obsession with giving significance of
events that are like ultimately
absolutely insignificant and no one
cares about but that is what is
considered making history not changing
anything at all about whatever the board
would call reality it's just we made
history because we have a new stat to
refer to yeah isn't that just like yeah
the barsm it's just like a euphemism for
first time that's ever happened well I
think we need to read deeper into it
Victor not take it for what it's worth
on its faces all right listeners there's
a lower ring of the bar going on I think
here all right all right sometimes if
there is no lazy language use if there
is no Collective history that we forged
together then everything is just making
history and then there's nothing
yeah all right everybody it's done we
can find it we can find it to the Past
see you later put our planet Capital I'm
bored with Deborah so I'm done the
boring the boring cut that out
all right all right
[Music]